all right uh nothing fancy last night
about monday night football and and last
night i said this all day yesterday you
earned your football card like your pga
tour card for another three years if you
watched all of last night's game because
there was nothing exciting about it
unless you had money on it but as a
football fan there was no real reason to
watch it and it was a struggle
especially early on when the dolphins
were up 14 nothing the steelers seemed
lifeless coming out of their bye week
they seemed lifeless they finally got it
together they won the game 27-14 and big
cap we were talking about this on the
little two minute stub that we do before
the radio uh show rejoins at the top of
the second hour of the program the
steelers turned the game around in one
fell swoop third and 20 from the miami
45 with 17 seconds left in the first
half down 14-3 the steelers hit a
touchdown pass a catch and a run by
rookie dante johnson but it was fueled
by the decision
of the dolphins to send pretty much
everyone on third and 20 with 17 seconds
left in the first half and it blew up my
god if you're watching on tv there is
nothing but green grass for deontay
johns he makes a nice move down near the
10-yard line to get into the end zone
but there is nothing in the middle of
the field he could have run 90 yards
with this thing
mind-numbingly stupid the only thing you
could say in defense of the dolphins
here is that maybe they are truly trying
to tank so badly that they sent everyone
on a blitz because if you're trying to
tank and you're trying to lose you don't
want guys to stop trying for you you
don't want to lose the locker room so to
speak and i thought the dolphins showed
a lot of fight in the first half so how
do you do how do you basically lose well
not showing that you're trying to lose
you call up a blitz on third and 20 with
23 seconds left and let the steelers
score a touchdown mike i actually
thought the dolphins for a little bit
there it looked like they could hang in
this game maybe even win this game and
if you do the math this was the game
that they should have tried to win
because they have the steelers first
round pick and it would have actually
helped their
you know draft status by winning this
one and then losing to the bengals but
they weren't able to hang on
and uh i think the dolphins weirdly
enough they still have the jets twice
and they have that bengals game i don't
think the dolphins are the worst team in
the nfl i know they're actively trying
to lose i know we have the ravens
drumming from week one stuck in our
brains forever but i don't think the
dolphins i think they they you know ryan
fitzpatrick does enough and he has that
fits fits magic thing he had it going on
in the first half where he can make
plays with pretty much anyone and i
think the bengals are the worst team in
the nfl and i actually think the
dolphins will win that game and maybe
not get the first pick even though
that's what they're trying to go for
they're actively trying to tank yeah i
think the moment that brian flores went
back to ryan fitzpatrick that was the
indication from him
that he's not actively involved in this
effort to sink to the bottom of the
standings or maybe he just realizes it
doesn't matter so i'll create the
impression i'm not in on the tank even
though the end result is they're going
to be one of the worst teams in the nfl
if not the very worst i kind of like
that logic of hey you know what we're
trying to win so let's be so overly
aggressive it helps us lose which is
exactly what they did and that's exactly
how brian flores explained it after the
game let's listen to what flores had to
say as to that specific question of why
he called for a blitz on third and 20
with 17 seconds left in the half
i want to be aggressive i mean
and we can second guess a lot of calls
and i'm not going to second guess that
one um i think we had success with the
call and
you know they made a play
yeah look we want to be aggressive we're
here all the time i want to be
aggressive want to be aggressive not
going to second-guess it well if you're
not going to second-guess it you're not
going to learn anything from it right
hey you you're going to do it again so
you're going to let your opponents know
hey we get them in 3rd and 20. they're
going to call in all out blitz because
they like to be aggressive i i just
think that there's there's an important
aspect of being an nfl head coach big
cat where you have to be able to tell
your story to defend yourself in those
press conference settings and it has to
be something that is plausible but you
but you don't want to go in there and
say i screwed up i mean there's a sweet
spot and i think brian flores was not in
it obviously last night when he came off
as stubborn these guys want to double
down and triple down and we're going to
be talking more about that later in the
show as it relates to your guy matt nagy
the coach of the bears there's a certain
point we have to acknowledge that it
didn't work i mean
we're being aggressive and i don't have
any second guessing but it didn't work
so
you have to have some second guessing
because your aggressive call failed
yeah no you're absolutely right there is
that fine balance where you can't get in
front of the media and just say you know
what i screwed up and i don't know what
i'm doing up here that's kind of the
freddie kitchen's approach when he says
i need i have things i need to learn and
you don't want to be the matinee who's
so stubborn to a fault and doubles and
triples down
on a really stupid statement monday
morning so you got to find that middle
ground and brian flores didn't really
kind of toe that line there i i think
more than anything
for uh you know watching week eight and
everything that happened joe flacco was
the best you know how to give a press
conference brian flores should basically
sit in front of everyone and say listen
we're bad football team we haven't won a
game everyone thinks we're a joke we're
going to pick our spots to be overly
aggressive because we have nothing to
lose we've already lost everything we're
a really bad football team so when
you're when you are a team like this
when you have a you know a two win team
a one win team a zero win team like the
dolphins you really do have nothing to
lose it's similar to the redskins game
when they go for two at the end of the
game to try to win that game right then
and there i have no problem with it
because if you explain it that way and
you say we are really really bad and
it's not like we're fighting for a
playoff spot here we just want to try to
win a game and we are going to throw
different things at the wall here and
hope something sticks i think that that
actually plays for the media and i would
i would respect that if brian flores
said something like that look we're
trying new things and we're trying
things that might work because right now
nothing is working and we can't get a
win
and you know it's funny as you as you
explain that it occurs to me over the
past five or six years as coaches have
gotten more aggressive in going for two
and going forward on fourth down and
they're no longer ripped for it when
they go for it on fourth down and they
fail i mean they are sometimes but not
like it used to be where it was
unthinkable to go forward on fourth and
shorten your own territory now there's
analytics that back it up at the same
time i feel like these desperate teams
these teams that have nothing to play
for aren't as over the top aggressive as
they used to be with fake punts and fake
field goals and just crazy stuff because
who cares we're just trying to win a
game and that is the best explanation
we're just trying to win a game we
picked a spot to be overly aggressive
and we thought we would get this
quarterback who was deer in the
headlights for most of the first half we
thought we would rattle him we thought
he wouldn't make a throw and you know
what give the kid credit he made a throw
but we're desperate and we did something
aggressive and that's what you do when
you're on six that's a much better
explanation than yeah okay we're trying
to be aggressive and it kind of worked
and no it didn't and we do it again we
have no second thoughts we're not going
to learn from our mistakes i mean that
part of it is just ludicrous to me and
and it just shows you that no matter how
good of a coordinator an assistant coach
you are
when you step into the job of head coach
your world changes dramatically and i
don't know that it's anything you can
even learn you either are wired to
thrive in that setting or you aren't now
maybe brian flores will improve on the
fly but it's just disappointing to see
these young coaches who just don't have
the instincts to understand how you need
to convey your thoughts and find that
that balance and just be candid i mean
it's just coach speak and it's
gobbledygook and it's defensive and it
really isn't something that resonates
and connects with fans that's ultimately
what it needs to be whatever you say if
you just say it in a way that gets the
fans on your side you've won the battle
yeah honesty goes a really long way when
it comes to coaches trying to explain
their decision making because
coaches have an impossible job we are
all going to second guess everything
they do that's what fans do that's what
people sitting on the couch everyone
thinks they can be smarter than the
coach and guess what we're not smarter
than the coach but when they when they
are stubborn in their responses and
maybe like you know really dig in and
don't
say hey look i make mistakes too i i
screw some things up i want to try to
win a game i want to be aggressive i
want to try new things just being honest
about it would go a long way and this is
all just foreshadowing for matt nagy and
the disaster that's going on right now
in chicago but i think it it holds true
for basically any coach who isn't
established who doesn't have that uh
established media relationship
relationship with the fans where fans
can trust whatever they do because that
this is really what it comes down to
mike when you're a new coach in the nfl
there will you will always have the
benefit you will never have the benefit
of the doubt people will always assume
that you're not qualified for the job
until you prove it until you start
winning and winning fast so it when it
comes to these new coaches when it comes
to brian flores or freddie kitchens or
even matt nakey who won coach of the
year last year he still doesn't have
enough goodwill built up for people to
just blindly say whatever he does i
trust this guy knows what he's doing
there are very few coaches in the nfl
who have that type of good will with the
media and the fan base so
watching a coach come into that
situation and try to navigate that
relationship is always fascinating
because it's a very hard one to build up
that trust and that and have everyone
say you know what whatever this coach
does i know they're trying to win i know
they're trying to put the team in a good
spot because right now i can't tell you
if that's true for those three guys i
just mentioned brian floors freddie
kitchens and matt nagy
and then there's mike tomlin who won a
super bowl in his second year as coach
of the steelers and has lifetime job
security at least it feels like he's
never had a losing season in pittsburgh
and now his team is at three and four
you look back to that ravens game from a
few weeks ago if they pull that one out
they're four and three and the ravens
are four and three but you know i've
tried to boil this down and keep it very
simple for the steelers the task comes
down to this big cat they have the
bengals again they've already beaten
them once they've got the browns twice
if they win those three games
and they are within a game of the ravens
going into week 17
that game is the afc north championship
because the ravens have a separate
divisional loss to the browns so they
would split the season series if the
steelers beat the ravens the next
tiebreaker is division record and the
steelers would prevail on that because
they'd be five and one in the division
and the ravens would be four and two
it's that simple beat the bengals beat
the browns twice be within a game of the
ravens going into week 17 and week 17 is
for all the marbles now i'm not saying
it's easy but it's simple and it's
amazing given how poorly the steelers
started to have them in position where
we can have this conversation halfway
through the season uh and how about
maybe putting in duck hodges because
mason rudolph did not look like he was i
mean he cleaned up at the end of the
game but to start the game not ready for
prime time some really bad throws and
you know
maybe because the bye week people forget
how good
duck hodges looked against the chargers
on sunday night football but that what
you just described and the schedule the
steelers have ahead of them they have it
all there like
they control their own destiny right now
they can basically the path is there but
there's no margin for error and you
can't have a bad game from mason rudolph
mason rudolph has the game he had last
night against a competent team with the
with the real you know uh defense and
offense they don't win that game so i
think that they dodged one last night
with some subpar quarterback play and
can they continue to do that because
they just have one slip up if you have
one slip up against the browns if you
have one slip up against these teams
that you think you should beat then it's
over for the steelers this year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports